the NHS has announces so worried about
children gambling it's set up a clinic
to help the thousands of kids they
believe are hooked not that long ago it
was very difficult to gamble betting
shops only became legal in the 60s and
even after the state went to some
lengths to stop people gambling I know
about this because my grandfather was a
compulsive gambler only if he had a big
wing win of the Hackney dogs he used to
celebrate by getting a taxi home and
putting his bike on the top that didn't
happen very often now on 80 years and
gambling has gone from being a shady
pursuit to becoming respectable it's
easy for anyone including children to
bet on line and bookies are spending at
least 1.5 billion a year on marketing to
attract punters the result is record
numbers of people gambling and getting
into financial problems because of it
both toy and labour governments have
played their part in liberalizing
gambling but will either party have the
nerve to do anything to stop it
from damaging our society even more than
it already has
[Music]
yeah well I think the production team is
skilfully picked me to respond to you
because I am a massive fan of the
gambling industry I see yeah yeah I
think the billions that they paying
taxes builds untold schools and untold
hospitals and I want to challenge a
couple of your lines it's easy for
children to bet on line no it's it but
it is illegal is it so and then you can
and then you say counter bookmakers pays
3.4 3.2 billion pounds to lure punters
not to lure underaged punters this is an
industry which when you go to a
bookmakers there's actually so how much
do they spend on warning people off when
the fun stops stop
they put an advert in a newspaper
there's the slogan you walk past the
window there's a it would be like pub
saying if you think you've had one drink
to money please leave immediately or
whatever it might be so of course there
are issues this is of grave concern it
is shocking the children of that age are
being lured in but this easy go at the
bookmakers who have seen almost as bad
as I don't know television presenters or
radio presenters they really are that
that loathesome is unfair they try and
do it responsibly they've taken the hit
over FOB t's fixed odds betting
terminals that's
cost over 10,000 they've taken the hit
and they said I didn't want to do which
they didn't but now obviously they've
had no choice stores have closed over
10,000 people have lost their jobs it
never needed to go down to to quit there
was a middle ground but we're going
automatic so I think broadly it's an
incredibly responsible industry it puts
a lot of money in attacks but this has
to be addressed
we cannot which is already illegal i've
massively disagree with you okay my
argument I think is that what happens in
this system is that there are kids who
are getting involved there are what you
saying doesn't that you made that much
sense in terms of the young people
saying that they're not marketing to
young people they're doing something
because the stats of the moments found
that in 2018 14 percent of 11 to 16 year
olds spent their own money on gambling
in the past week that's approximately
450,000 young people specifically target
really do need to get that in the public
eye they don't have like the pictures I
think there's something about that
marketing that's appealing to these
young people and then of that 1.7
percent of the 11 to 16 year olds were
classified as problem gamblers that's a
serious no I agree that's horrible I
want to come to your point because you
say that that you know that they they
help in this you know they tried to help
let's see what Simon Stevin says from
he's that he's they when he was the
chief executive of NHS England he says
this is an industry that splashes 1.5
billion pounds on marketing and
advertising campaigns much of it now
pumped out online through social media
but it has been spending just a fraction
of that helping customers and their
families families do with the direct
consequences of addiction a levy to fund
evidence-based NHS treatment research
and education can substantially increase
the money available so the taxpayers in
the NHS are not left to pick up a huge
tab and that's the point isn't it you
know I think I think in a way well we're
all talking about situation if the
government is going to be very loath to
tackle this because it gets 2 billion
quid ear in taxes from the gambling
interests it's going to be your brave
government that does it but you know the
gambling is we has to address the
problem as it causes and it has to help
pay for them basically enough and that's
what that's what's a maturely
you come I mean walking on your side to
extend I can have a little rest the
difficult thing here the difficult thing
is the rights of the individual versus
the damaging can be done you're the one
who's always going on about the nanny
state the years we have allowed people
to gamble in a way that we wouldn't have
done both governments allowed this and
so I don't think it's I don't think
governments have got the relaxants
because of the tax take I think that we
like this is about the individuals
rights but but what do you do when you
discover actually by giving you're
damaging children and you're damaging
lots of families I completely agree with
that and I think you know Nick I can see
where you're coming from and this isn't
necessarily about painting the gambling
industry is evil it's about just
accepting the reality yeah that their
actions are disproportionately targeting
children and the statistics speak for
themselves notice that and I think it's
interesting as well to think about how
things are changing for that generation
alcohol consumption is down tobacco
consumption if now say is is that but
they are gambling in growing numbers
this is something that is affecting
young people and it's a shift in their
behavior and also I think we need to
think about the psychology of young
people just listen to a Philip Newell
this young man has to say about the way
children think about gambling mm-hmm
kids don't quite understands the
persuasive element of gambling
advertising for example a lot of
gambling adverse we'll see will say here
we're going to give you some free money
now kids kind of take that claim at face
value and they don't properly
understands that you know when it's the
gambling industry saying we're gonna
give you three money it's actually
they're gonna give you free money with
various caveats so they're only going to
give you free money if you then gamble
with them sufficiently afterwards
and it's quite hard for both kids and
adults to understand these issues the
regulation that exists is not protecting
children from gambling messages that are
affecting them in ways that maybe adults
can't see why what if we accept that but
I do yeah what do we do about it
interesting Hector 24/7 by the nanny
state about what we eat what we don't
look back in there and yet the very
thing there's no censure over gambling
Sainsbury's azarel Waitrose for young
people you and I actually almost on the
same page because of course this is
reprehensible all I'm trying to say is I
do think the gambling industry have
taken can they do more of course they
can and I'm sure Sainsbury's and astron
Waitrose can do more to stop children of
it but it's not as if they just glide
glibly walk away and don't care they
spend a phenomenal amount of marketing
and a tiny fraction of that on
preventive and own voluntary target for
putting money back in with successive
governments continually presents us with
more opportunities to gamble and on the
other hand they say how terrible isn't
about individual responsibility that
you're allowed to do things that
previously you weren't allowed to do and
the trouble is it's had some effects
that we don't like as a society now do
we go back and say okay but make it less
of it let's have a free society because
of the damage or do we just say that's
what you have to live with I don't know
but I think the other problems the fact
that the industry or the government
hasn't been prepared for the fact that
the majority of gambling is now moving
online so therefore you do have that
anonymity you know with the old betting
shops if a young kid walked in you can
see those and again this is the whole
idea of social bit how on earth because
they will find a way around it
whatever you do that's what young people
have put on earth to do whatever they
find a way around that's the point of
being young isn't it and that's what the
industry will have to wrestle with how
they some put in the toys you do you
make it that's the real question how can
you make this much more difficult don't
know and could you know you're praising
that you know the cameras are how good
they are you know young support okay
okay literally that's for them it's all
about money before deregulation all
these years
deregulation I think the prophets more
effective was about 4.5 billion and let
me stop while she's still on that roll
she'll be back shortly
next debate the old one will be back and
you're watching the pledge on Sky News
up after the break why we could be
seeing a dangerous backlash against me
too
[Music]